[Music]
we begin in Ecuador where thousands of
police and soldiers have raided a prison
to remove a powerful gang leader he's
accused of threatening presidential
candidate Fernando Villa vicencio a week
before his killing the Man known as fito
has now been transferred to a Maximum
Security Prison he's been serving a
34-year prison term for a drug dealing
and murder offense authorities have
linked him to the Mexican drug gang at
the Sinaloa cartel up to 4 000 officers
were involved in the joint operation at
a prison in the country's second largest
city guayakil
well following the assassination of via
vicencio on Wednesday Ecuador's
presidential candidate submission a
statement blaming the government for
political violence in the country his
running mate Andrea Gonzalez has offered
to take his place he was a vocal critic
of corruption and organized crime six
suspects have been arrested police say
they are linked to criminal gangs
well earlier my colleague Kerry Johnston
spoke to Manuela Peak from the
Universidad San Francisco de Quito she
doesn't believe moving the gang leader
will make any difference to security
he was moved to another prison today but
it's a prison from which he escaped back
in 2008 so we don't know how much this
is actually going to change the
situation the root of the matter is that
criminal gangs have been answering
politics in what is becoming a narco
state in Ecuador so we can move the
heads from one jail to the other but the
reality is that the level of corruption
has secured over the last decades the
participation of various criminal gangs
into institutionalized politics and they
are Allied and associated with very
political parties I understand you are
campaign manager and wife of one of the
candidates Jaco Perez I mean on a human
level How concerned are you about safety
we're all very scared about our safety
beloved into the last one but once a
week we have had colleagues assassinated
we're all wearing bulletproof jackets
some of us helmets we were all using
bulletproof cars so it's a very high
level of insecurity and Terror for
ourselves and our families and what is
the most scary scariest is that we don't
think there is a return
um in the near future we think there is
a narcotization of politics in Ecuador
and at the international level I would
compare this with the afghanization of
Ecuadorian politics in which there are
lots of uh Regional geopolitics Global
geopolitics that play in the local
context and ecuadorians are going to pay
a price for years to come
well via vicenzio's Widow has held a
press conference Veronica at Oz says the
ecuadoran authorities should be held
accountable for her husband's killing
they did not protect him as they should
have protected him the state was in
charge of Fernando's security the state
is directly responsible for the murder
of my husband the state still has to
give many answers about everything that
happened his personal guards did not do
their job I do not want to think that
they sold my husband to be murdered in
this way
Latin America editor Lucia Newman has
more from Ecuador's Capital Quito
well first she made an extremely
dramatic entrance Veronica saraus came
in with a with a bulletproof helmet and
she was also accompanied by a policeman
with a with a helmet of the same size
and were carrying an automatic weapon
kind of pointing it at the media that
was there we hadn't been searched so it
was rather strange but then she said
that first of all she blamed the state
of Ecuador or for not having provided
sufficient security to save her husband
for not having provided a bulletproof
vehicle while he was campaigning and
then she went on to denounce the his
running mate Andrea Gonzalez who had
just earlier today was nominated as his
replacement at the Electoral laws in
Ecuador say that if a candidate steps
down or dies or for whatever reason
cannot run his political party has to
replace him or her with someone else
well and Gonzalez was the running mate
she has said that she will run but now
according to the abcenso's Widow that is
quote an outrage and illegal and she
said she would not stand for it she says
that would destroy her husband's Legacy
and would mean that his death had been
in vain and I'm quoting her now she is
referring of course to the Electoral
laws of this country which apparently do
not allow a person who has already been
registered to run for example as a vice
presidential candidate to switch it
during the middle of the campaign but we
haven't heard yet from the Electoral
authorities yet on that matter